revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa pérez más de borrosa bienvenida a
feliz lunes iniciamos de semana en
italia donde hoy empieza la elección del
nuevo presidente de la república nos
fijamos en el medio francés liberación
que se dedica a uno de sus artículos
principales de este lunes se titula en
italia una presidencial que agita el
medio al vacío en el gobierno porque
dice esto rosa bueno es de aragón porque
como ya comentamos un poco el viernes
pasado tiene lugar a partir de hoy lo
que no significa para nada que se vaya a
resolver precisamente este mismo lunes
la elección del próximo presidente de
italia y este artículo de liberación nos
contextualiza un poco pues cómo va a
desarrollarse esta votación que empieza
a las 3 de la tarde hora de italia
recordamos a que las personas que votan
quién va a ser el nuevo jefe del estado
italiano son mil nueve grandes electores
entre los cuales pues en los senadores
los diputados y representantes
regionales nos recuerda que las primeras
en las primeras tres vueltas lecciones
hace falta una mayoría cualificada de
dos tercios lo que parece que no se va a
alcanzar ni de lejos en estas primeras
tres vueltas por ejemplo nos dice este
artículo que en
1971 hicieron falta 23 vueltas para
elegir a el jefe del estado no sabemos
cuántas van a ser necesarias en esta
ocasión lo que sí está claro es que la
primera no se va a resolver porque no
hay un candidato de momento pues que
consiga aglutinar a todo el espectro
necesario para ser elegido lo que sí que
podemos avanzar es que el primer
ministro actual mario draghi es uno de
los favoritos precisamente de aquí el
titular de este texto que abre este
miedo a un vacío en el gobierno porque
si mario draghi es elegido presidente de
la república pues se abre la incógnita
sobre quién lo sustituiría al frente del
gabinete de ministros y bien a este
texto explica como las cúpulas de los
partidos políticos están intentando bien
ver quién podría sustituir a mario
draghi al frente del gobierno o quién
podría ser otro presidente de la red
pública que pues consiguiera generar
también una unidad política en italia no
está entonces clara las cosas en italia
y quien será el próximo presidente rosa
pero si continuamos nosotros en europa
vamos a el país que aborda la polémica
con una especial sobre el funcionamiento
de unas de macro granjas el titular es
macro granjas paso a paso un proceso
industrial para crear 53 millones de
cerdos al año esto lo firman cinco
periodistas los exacto y es que el tema
de las macro granja raúl entró en la
agenda mediática y política española
pero con mucha fuerza a raíz de unas
declaraciones que hizo alberto garzón el
ministro de consumo de españa en el
medio británico the guardian a raíz de
ahí la derecha la oposición de la
derecha y de la extrema derecha
instrumentalizó digamos estas
declaraciones defendiendo esta industria
que se considera de ganadería súper
intensiva y defendiendo la no pero
precisamente distintos medios como en
este caso el país nos han querido
explicar cómo funciona realmente este
comercio tan intensivo y empezamos tal y
como pues señala este artículo todo
empieza con una cerda reproductora
encerrada en una jaula de gestación como
veíamos de muy poca pues con 60
centímetros de ancho donde apenas puede
moverse donde están inseminada
artificialmente
ahí vive aproximadamente unas cuatro
semanas donde pues se defeca
precisamente en el mismo lugar y estos
excrementos mezclados con el agua y con
la paja da lugar a esta sustancia que se
llaman los purines y que descontrolados
pues generan problemas de contaminación
tanto de emisión de gases en el aire
como de contaminación de los acuíferos
pero más allá esta cerda cuando tiene
que parir está salada a otra a otro tipo
de celda donde pues ahí da a luz y
alimenta durante semanas también a sus
crías también como vemos a tiene un
espacio en el que apenas logran moverse
finalmente la cerda será sacrificada a
los tres años mientras que en los
lechones son engordados hasta los 108
120 kilos durante unos seis meses y a
posteriori son también cabe destacar que
en libertad la vida de un cerdo puede
llegar a durar hasta unos 15 años bien
aquí tenemos un gráfico que muestra pues
esta contaminación a través de los
purines pero en resumen este artículo
que es muy extenso les invitamos a que
pues se detengan a leerlo concluye que
la unión europea precisamente está
intentando acabar con estas
explotaciones súper intensivas de
ganadería mientras que en españa va
creciendo este negocio que triste de
rosa vamos al diario punto es que
publicar de un albarán amazonía para que
una persona se puede comer un cerdo de
macro granja en españa' exacto como
comentábamos pues otro medio que ha
arrojado luz a este tema en este caso
hablar de los vínculos internacionales
con este negocio dice grandes
extensiones de bosque arden en la
amazonía para que coman cerdos de macro
granjas al otro lado del océano
atlántico en europa después buena parte
de la carne de los animales criados y
sacrificados en grandes explotaciones de
españa por ejemplo acabará vendido en
china y aquí vemos la ejercicio no está
la de la que sí está la que arde en la
amazonía brasileña o en el norte de
argentina para dar lugar a las
plantaciones de soja que posteriormente
se utilizan para el pienso de los cerdos